G.O.P. UNION
G.O.P. UNIFIRE THAT'S THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
DO YOU REMEMBER THOSE
DIVIDE AND DESTROY THE
G.O.P.?
OH, THERE THEY ARE.
WELL, IT TURNS OUT THAT THE
PRESIDENT MAY WELL BE ON HIS
WAY TO HEALING THOSE
DIVISIONS.
WELL, SURE, THERE ARE STILL
SOME POLICY DISAGREEMENTS,
ON THE BIG ISSUES, THE UNITY
OF SPIRIT AND PURPOSE IS
KIND OF REMARKABLE.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE
ACKNOWLEDGED.
YOU THINK ABOUT WHERE THE
G.O.P. WAS IN LET'S SAY 2008
OR 2012, EARLY 2016.
AND NOW THINK ABOUT WHERE IT
IS TODAY.
ONCE UPON A TIME THE
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP HAD
WHO CRASHED THEIR PARTY.
JUST REMEMBER THE KINDS OF
THINGS THE G.O.P. LEADERSHIP
HAD SAID ABOUT TRUMP.
>> OUR NEW PRESIDENT OF
COURSE HAD NOT BEEN IN THIS
ABOUT HOW QUICKLY THINGS
HAPPEN IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS.
>> CLAIMING A PERSON CAN'T
DO THEIR JOB BECAUSE OF
THEIR RACE IS SORT OF LIKE
THE TEXTBOOK DEFINITION OF A
RACIST COMMENT.
I THINK THAT SHOULD BE
ABSOLUTELY DISAVOWED.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> YOU WOULD THINK HE WOULD
ASPIRE TO BE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND ACT
LIKE A PRESIDENT OF THE
NOT GOING TO BE THE CASE
APPARENTLY.
THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS A
DIVISIVE FIGURE WHO WASN'T
WAYS OF WASHINGTON.
OH, REALLY?
I WAS TOLD BY MULTIPLE
CONGRESSIONAL SOURCES THAT
THE PRESIDENT WORKED THE
PHONES TIRELESSLY TO GET
THIS TAX BILL DONE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE HAS BEEN INTIMATELY
INVOLVED IN REMAKING TRADE
POLICY TO BENEFIT THE
AMERICAN WORKER AS WELL.
AND, OF COURSE, HIS EFFORTS
TO REVIVE THE ECONOMY SEEM
TO BE PAYING OFF.
HOME SALES HIT THEIR HIGHEST
LEVEL IN 10 YEARS.
STOCK MARKET BREAKING ALL
KIND OF RECORDS.
AND NAU THE PRESIDENT HAS
TURNED SOME OF HIS FIERCEST
CRITICS INTO ALLIES.
LISTEN TO THEM NOW.
>> YEAR OF EXTRAORDINARY
ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
SOMETHING THIS PROFOUND
COULD NOT HAVE BEEN DONE
WITHOUT EXQUISITE
PRESIDENTIAL LEADERSHIP.
>> I HAVE NEVER EVER IN MY
LIFE USED THE WORD FAKE
MUST
NEWS.
UNTIL TODAY I ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN DEALING
WITH.
>> Laura: NOT ONLY IS THAT A
STUNNING REVERSAL OF THE
VIEW OF THE PRESIDENT'S
ON A NUMBER OF KEY ISSUES.
SO, FOR INSTANCE, WHEN IS
THE LAST TIME A PROMINENT
REPUBLICAN REALLY COMPLAINED
ABOUT TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO
RENEGOTIATE NAFTA OR
CHALLENGE CHINA?
AND IN CASE YOU DIDN'T
MOVEMENT THAT SWEPT HIM IN
TO OFFICE.
HIS DETRACTORS ARE NOW
REALIZING THAT THE TRUMP WAY
IS THE ONLY WAY FORWARD.
THERE IS SIMPLY NO
CONSTITUENCY FOR THE G.O.P.
OF OPEN BORDERS, ENDLESS
WARS, AND THOSE LOPSIDED
G.O.P.?
YOU SEE THEM THERE.
THE BUSHES, JEFF FLAKE, MITT
ROMNEY, AND OTHER BITTER
GLOBALISTS WHOSE TIME HAS
FRANKLY COME AND GONE.
LIKE THE GHOSTS OF CHRISTMAS
ONE IS LISTENING.
THIS IS A TRUMPIAN PARTY